>> Will: WELCOME BACK TO A
SPECIAL EDITION OF "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
WHEN DANA WHITE FIRST GOT
INVOLVED IN THE UFC BACK IN
2001, HE NEVER IMAGINED THAT THE
SPORT WOULD ALLOW FEMALE
ATHLETES, UNTIL RONDA ROUSEY
BECAME ONE OF THE MOST FAMOUS
FEMALE ATHLETES IN THE WORLD.
>> Tucker: SO WHEN YOU GOT INTO
THIS 22 YEARS AGO, DID YOU
IMAGINE THERE COULD BE A
CATEGORY FOR FEMALE FIGHTERS?
>> NO.
WHAT YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND IS
AT THAT TIME I WAS TRYING TO GET
PEOPLE TO ACCEPT MEN FIGHTING IN
A CAGE, WHICH PEOPLE THOUGHT WAS
HORRIBLE.
I SAW A FIGHT UP IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WITH TWO WOMEN.
THAT WAS A HORRIBLE MISMATCH.
AND I WAS, LIKE, OH, MY GOD.
NOBODY'S READY FOR THIS.
THEN I MET RONDA ROUSEY.
>> Tucker: AND IT WAS UGLY?
>> IT WAS UGLY.
YOU SEE A WOMAN ON HER BACK
TAKING ELBOWS TO THE FACE SHE
CAN'T DEFEND, THAT SHE SHOULDN'T
HAVE EVEN BEEN IN THIS FIGHT.
IT'S ROUGH TO SEE, YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW, AGAIN, I GREW UP IN --
IT COMES OFF CHAUVINISTIC
SOMETIMES, BECAUSE WE LIVE IN A
DAY AND AGING WHERE WOMEN WANT
TO BE EQUAL.
BELIEVE ME WHEN I TELL YOU,
WOMEN HAVE PROVEN HERE THAT THEY
ARE EQUAL.
ONE OF THE GREATEST FIGHTS THAT
YOU WILL EVER SEE IN YOUR
LIFE -- I DON'T MEAN FEMALE
FIGHTS.
ONE OF THE GREATEST FIGHTS
YOU'LL EVER SEE IS THAT FIGHT.
THEY HAVE ABSOLUTELY PROVEN
THEMSELVES.
AND PEOPLE LOVE THE WOMEN'S
FIGHTS.
THEY'RE SO TACTICAL AND SO GOOD.
IT'S JUST I DIDN'T SEE IT
COMING.
I DIDN'T SEE IT HAPPENING THAT
FAST, WOMEN GETTING -- EVEN
WOMEN BOXING BACK IN THE DAY, IT
WAS LIKE A NOVELTY.
THEY HAD NO DEFENSE, SO THEY'D
STAND IN FRONT OF EACH OTHER AND
JUST FLAIL AWAY.
PEOPLE WOULD GO CRAZY.
NOBODY WAS, LIKE, WOW, THAT
WOMAN IS SUPER TALENTED.
SHE'S -- YOU KNOW, HER STYLE OF
FIGHTING OR THIS OR THAT.
HERE, THESE WOMEN ARE
UNBELIEVABLE.
THEY'RE TECHNICAL AND VERY GOOD.
>> Tucker: AND YOU KNOW FROM THE
NUMBERS THAT THE AUDIENCE
RESPONDS?
>> NO.
THE AUDIENCE DOESN'T RESPOND.
THE AUDIENCE LOVES IT.
WHEN I PUT A REAL GOOD WOMAN'S
FIGHT ON THE CARD, A LOT OF
PEOPLE SHOW UP.
WHY ARE YOU HERE?
I WANT TO SEE AMANDA NUNES
VERSUS JULIANNA PENA, RONDA
ROUSEY.
THESE WOMEN HAVE BECOME BIG
STARS.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
FAMOUS.
>> YEAH.
IT'S AWESOME.
WHAT'S DIFFERENT FROM US, THESE
WOMEN ARE AS EQUAL AS THE MEN.
THEY FIGHT THE SAME AMOUNT OF
ROUNDS IN NONTITLE FIGHTS.
ROUNDS IN CHAMPIONSHIP FIGHTS.
THEY GET PAID THE SAME AS THE
MEN DO.
THEY DON'T FIGHT FROM A SHORTER
TEE.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY EQUALLY FOR
WOMEN AND MEN.